okay thank you so I'll continue on the
same topic of computing this um map but
I'll just switch from discrete to
continuous uh variables right um um and
this is actually um what I'm showing is
most of the work of my Farmer student
Thiago and Al talk some work that I did
with c not so
recent so just to to get everyone on the
same page so I'll I'll be concerned with
some product Network which just this
problemistic circuit which is um smooth
and um and and
decomposable and one difference is that
um I will be assuming that you have um
univariated distributions at the leaves
right instead of having indicators and
so that we can generalize two continuous
variables right and in particular I
would be concerned with the uh with
modules where you have gaan on the
leaves right this is just representing
like a gaan distribution
with mean 11 and variance
eight
um so a mode of um of a protic circuit
or of of any um distribution is just a
local maximum right just a point that um
in terms of the density that it
represents you can find some
neighborhood where that thing is a is a
maximum um of course if you're
considering um the discrete case then
maybe the neighborhood something that
you need to specify right so in the
continuous case usually you would take a
like a ball in the discrete case you can
take hemming distance or some bounded
Hing distance some kind of stuff like
that right so for this network here if
you just plot the density you get this
image and then the the modes would just
be the the Peaks
right um and why do we want to find
modes um well um one of the reasons is
that the modes of the distributions they
are a good summary of your distributions
right there a way that you can have to
look into the distributions if you if
you want to like um um um let's say
transform your distribution which is you
know this very complex object in some
examples that you can just inspect and
see what exactly is my distribution en
coding then you can that the modes are
good candidates for that right and um in
a way you are looking at the at the at
the max ma of some regions and then you
can see if this local maximum they they
make sense or not right if they are very
probable or not so you can see if
perhaps you are in a region that you
have a lot of modes and that's probably
not a very smooth distribution and that
might not be actually a good thing right
or or maybe it is just the way it is
because you are representing very
complex data and you might need a lot of
mode and something like that right
um and and if I just give you an
arbitrary probility circuit it might be
that there you have a a single mode
right and that's
um probably not a very interesting
circuit if that happens uh but for us
here that we're interesting in finding
modes is the perfect case um usually you
would have some finite number of modes
but it might also happen that you have
infinitely many modes right um that's a
bit weird because I already see Antonio
like making bad faces um and I will talk
about that but um even with gaussian
leaves we don't know if the number of
modes is bounded
right everybody believes so but uh it
could happen that you have some very
very bizarre thing and you end up with
infinitely many molds right uh okay but
and of course if you use just arbitrary
continuous distributions that the lives
then you can easily come up with an
example where you you know you just have
like a a region where everything is a
mold right like a donut
right okay so one particular um mode
that we are often interesting is a one
that has a high probability right or the
highest probability mode which is like
the maximum uh posterior inference with
Benjo just told us about which is just
one particular mode where you consider
the region to be the entire uh domain
right um and then we know something
about this so we know that the problem
in discrete um networks is NP we know
there is um n to approximate and the
approximation that we can get gets worse
and worse the deeper the the the network
gets um and we know that if we have
deterministic of Q deterministic
circuits then we can do it uh
efficiently right um and this is
actually um has um I say a lot of
applications right all this structur
predictions and data imputation M label
classification and stuff like that
that so let me just um give you some um
idea of why this is um difficult and
it's not very difficult to see so you
have many ways to prove uh one way for
instance is reducing from Maximum
independent set so the idea here is that
um you build this network where each one
of the product nodes is just encoding a
constraint that uh if you select that
node then you cannot select uh its
neighbors right so for instance in the
first product knowe that on the the on
the left um it's representing node one
here in this graph and there just saying
that if you select node one then you
cannot select the other nodes and I'm
doing this just by placing this
indicator distribution here right which
just gives ones if X1 is one zero
otherwise and then
um for the nodes that are not really
connected to all the nodes you will to
make it smooth you have to add some
uniform distributions which is a way of
saying I don't care what are the values
of those other variables right um and
then you can show that you have a
maximum independent set of certain set
if and only if the most probable
configuration is above some threshold
right and then because maximum
independent set does not allow
um um a very efficient approximation
then you can also show that that some
product networks which is very simple
structure uh cannot have a proximations
right can I have anything better than um
um um a linear Factor approximation in
the number of
yes how do you set this values with
calan leaves right
so
um so how do you set these variables
with gaussian leaves
um I haven't published this and I
thought that given that people have been
talking about gaan mixture models for so
long someone must have proved this
already right I've been looking a lot
and I haven't found it um so if someone
knows if this already was shown so I
think the trivial way would be just well
you take all those indicators and you
replace by some very narrow gaans right
and that kind of seems to work right
except that like if you work with
um um with two narrow um um gaan then
the problem is that is a bit difficult
to work with the bounds because you know
they can they they go above one and so
on so so actually it's not that good to
make them very narrow actually is it's
best to just you know you leave them as
for whatever variance and you just make
them very well spread right we just have
all the whole continuous line to place
our gaussion right so you just like
create one gum to represent the zero
indicator one gum to represent the one
indicator and you just make this thing
so far apart that you know for any
practical purposes is like they are
indicators right uh the proof it's a bit
boring because then you have a lot of uh
uh of inequalities right so yeah and yes
but I think it works right perhaps is
wrong but I think it works uh there is
kind of also another thing that we
cannot represent the uniform
distributions if we only using gaan
right but then you can use a gaan with
just a very wide uh variance right and I
think also it works but makes for a very
boring proof because you have this you
know everything there but I think you
have the same proofs right um what I'm
not so certain is that if you also get
the same approximability uh Properties
or no approximability
properts because uh I mean you have all
these numbers and actually you have uh
you know exponential to something right
so you kind of have real values there
I'm not 100% sure that the same no
inapproximability results hold if you
have
Gs
maybe okay
um and then we have we have SE Yun um
show some algs how you can do it there
is you know some other people that have
made branch and bound I have made some
not so elegant algorithms um you have
this um idea of how um try to transform
to
um cirquit to make it um work but I
think what most people do in practice
when they actually want to compute the
map is this Max product algorithm which
was um a very simple idea with which is
just like you forget about that this is
not really a deterministic circuit you
pretend it is and you just comput it as
it is right which is just the same as
saying um you greedily optimize over
each some node
right
um and then it's quite um easy to see
that this is just her istic right so for
instance here I have this very simple
Network which is a mixture of two gions
with the same weights and if you plot
the dist uh the the density you can see
that the mixture of the two is actually
just one gaan in the middle right and
and this Alor you you would always um
select the mode of one of the components
right so either these or this and in
this case is a bit arbitrary right
because they have the same um so we
would not select the the best one and
you can also see that you would probably
select something like here right which
would be I mean uh at bound the distance
from the top right and and that's why I
also think that the approximation should
still hold of course not because of this
example but because I think you will
always um I think you can show that that
if you if you are making a mistake but
you can probably find a mode that is a
bit close to to where you are uh but you
will not actually find the the optimal
one right um right so so this is a
limitation of this method is that you
are always just actually
finding um a component right one of the
components whatever that means when you
are actually in a very deep circuit
right which is not so clear what exactly
what a component is in that case um and
then one thing is that you can see the
diagram faing this very very simple
example where I have two
components one variable um you know just
one some no they don't even have product
noes and right so um yeah okay um
however um we can easily um also show
that algorthm uh it does find some
approximation right and then the idea is
that because the diagram acts um gridily
the one thing that you can show is that
like when you have product noes diagram
is actually optimal because you are just
like optimizing independently this this
joint to Scopes so the problem is
actually just when you have the sum
loads um and for instance if you only
have one Su Lo in your in your um in
your network then you essentially you
just have this um right you can just
like manipulate stuff and end up with a
circuit like
this and then what you can uh show is
that um um this guy here will be by
definition
the maximum over all of the other um
let's say inputs of this um some node
right so if you multiply this value by
the number of inputs you get something
that is uh above the optimum right which
is just what I'm showing here right so
this um so the optimal it needs to be
smaller than moving the the maximization
in size with what is what um the max
product algorithm is doing right and it
cannot be uh worse than just uh taking
this uh worst case and and placing the
same value in all of the input nodes
right so that means that you get this
linear approximation right linear Factor
approximation by um by Max product it's
uh it's not like very good right but
what we can show is that this is the
best possible right so uh we can show
that there is nothing uh better than
that so there is no sub linear there is
no approximation wam with a linear
Factor approximation for networks of
high two so for networks that have at
most one some
node and if you allow more than one some
node um well more than one layer of some
nodes then you cannot get anything
better than an approximation factor that
is like exponential in the size of the
circuit right which CES the number of
nodes and edes and and so on right uh so
in a way Max product is the best thing
we can get in the worst case right of
course you can do better um when you
have a fixed instance but as a as a
worst case is is the best you can do
right
um right so one thing is that um the
only thing I did that in that proof is I
just showed that you can act gradually
and you can easily find an upper bound
and this upper bound is Satisfied by Max
Max product I haven't um
um consider that they were discrete or
not right there was no mention of what
are exactly are their new evaluated
distributions so the same uh the same
bounds actually apply the same upper
bounds apply for whatever distribution
you have in the on the leaves right as
long as you can uh optimize those
distributions as long as you can find
the maximum value of those distributions
right um and then for the lower bond is
what I saying I think this is true for
gaan leaves but I'm not 100% sure
right
okay um and just to finish talking about
this um so I we started looking into
this because I just um talked to chag as
a student and say well you know people
have been doing a lot of work on gaon
mixture models um so looks like a a lwh
hanging fruit is just like go there see
all the alrs that they are doing for
gaung mixture models to find modes of
gaung mixture modeles and just you know
I that to some product networks right um
look at easy uh but then it turned out
that um essentially there is not that
much work in finding modes of Gan
mixture models which I find a bit
surprising given you know how much they
are use it and most of theams are
somehow simple stuff right including the
things that we did right they are more
like gradient Ascent or em stuff like
that right so the
usual um the one thing that I think is a
bit different and a bit interesting
thing um but we didn't really have time
to pursue this is this um is this type
of continuation methods right so the
idea is that you will smooth out your
your distribution into something that is
easy to find a mode or easier right and
and you do a kind of simulated theing
right and then you just move less and
less and less until at some point you
are in some region and you stick with
that mode right and the idea is that uh
if you do it this properly then you can
prove that you can and uh find a mode in
a area of high probability which is what
they call significant mode so not
necessarily the mode has high density or
high probability but it's around it's in
a neighborhood of high probability of
high density right so for instance like
um I don't know like this this guy here
is probably in an area of high
probability so if you draw a ball around
this guy it has most of the mass of the
density but it's not a very high density
mode right that's the uh the kind of
idea and for so this is a general method
and then for gaussian mixture models you
have this nice property that is if you
convolve a gaussian mixture with a
gaussian you get a gaussian mixture
model um with some weird variances but
you just get a gaan mixture
model um so um so this is interesting um
and then you can um show that under some
conditions this convolution if you
convolve with a gaan that has a very
light High variance then you can show
that is um it's a uni model right so
it's easy to find the mode of the
convolved one and also you can show a
mapping between the modes of the
convolved uh density and the original
modes it's not a trivial mapping because
you need to solve a partial differential
equation but you can do it somehow
numerically right um so you have this
very convoluted method but is it seems
to work really well and it's quite
different from everything that we have
been doing right um and one interesting
thing at least for Antonio is that
actually the method works with negative
weights for the for the mixtures um and
and in in this paper actually the guy
says that they they do have some
applications for negative weights which
I don't quite understand they kind of
try to model negative correlation and
they need these negative weights of the
so mixtures of gions with negative
weights
right um so it might be something that
someone wants to take a look at that
right and of course there is the point
of can we convolve a gaan with the with
a some product Network I have absolutely
no idea right so um what they do is they
have this closed form uh formula and uh
of course then it looks like we could do
it because you can just think of you
know like uh having all the components
of your thickers but then that would be
exponential and it's not clear if you
can do it efficiently right but you
might be if we convolve with an
isotropic Al we just need to add the
variant right yeah yeah yeah that's
essentially what this is doing yeah so
are you talking about convolving with a
full cover scussion or what I mean well
in in our cases always isotropic right
because I'm I'm assuming the leaves are
univariate
this is just yeah so what I'm asking is
like okay this is for a gaan mixure
model what if you have a deeper circuit
right is it still true
it's shallow yes yes but but that's not
efficient
right really just need to add the bares
to the Le I
guess
yeah
right um which you can think of um a
circuit
only right comp
always
right an i a paper called deconet where
Essen not with G but like with circuits
nonpr circuits and ENT
exactly okay let's talk and that would
be very cool
so this idea the image is just like this
is just some gaan mixture model and when
you convolve with the gaan you get the
distribution right which is very smooth
and has a single mode here and then if
you find the mode here then you can see
that you are in this region of high
probability and then you just do some
local search to convert to some other
better mode right okay so another
problem that we we might want is not
exactly to necessarily find the most
probable mode or you know the most in a
high probability region but just like
find some mode from some region right so
the idea is that if I give you a
starting point I want to uh just try to
uh find a mode that
has some kind of path from this point to
that mode
and you know that satisfies some
iterative procedure right and usually
the idea is that of course you want to
have a path of um like um non decreasing
probab
right
um but what we can um show with some um
interpretations of facts is that um
trying to find if there is an improving
point to a current one is also NP hard
so Badlander showed this for basan
networks and you can kind of massage his
construction to prove that also in
probalistic circuits with discrete
inputs uh we actually proved something
we're trying to prove some other um
model about robustness but in the end
that also implies that finding um you
know an improving model is best than
that which is similar to what we were
doing for
other reasons and of course if the p is
deterministic you can do it and you can
do it if somehow you define your
neighborhood is small enough right if
you're in the discrete case or or even
in the continuous case and you find I
just want to find one point that is
better than in some small region right
and this for instance has applications
in multiple imputation so when you want
you have some partial configuration then
you want to complete them but you want
to complete in several different ways to
get some diversity right so you can
start from any completion of your model
and then try to convert to a different
mode right just sample
completions um and also in modo
clustering which is going to show what's
that about
right so um so what people have been
doing in in Gan mixture models is either
gradient Ascent which works reasonably
well but you have all those problems of
gradient to define the learning rate and
and this kind of stuff and what seems to
work a bit better is this idea of
gaussian mean shift which is um kind of
a reinterpretation of the mean shift
alram that people use um you know long
ago but it's a kind of mean shift where
you actually have model instead of just
using the data as a as a model right um
so you kind of have this um complicated
equation but is a actually just simple
is just saying that you start with some
point you evaluate the um the density of
that point you kind of renormalize it
right and kind of compute the sort of
expectation of that point with respect
to this point and you get a new point
and you do that over and over again
until at some point you converge and you
can show that that converts to some mode
of the
distributions uh or it covers to a sadow
point right it's like
um um and then like independently people
came up with this variance inference
methods and then they actually showed
that this is just the same thing right
because this is what mostly like a her
istic was just saying oh we can do Ming
shift with the
distribution but yeah and then people
actually derived these equations and
they can show that they are just the
same even though it doesn't really look
like the
so the idea of these mod oems is just
like to have an expectation step where
you actually just compute this part here
right the expectation of this variable
and then a maximization where you try to
um to find the as a next point the guy
that maximizes this part here um and
then the interesting thing is that in
this part here you have the log right
which makes things um easier then it's
not exactly uh it's a kind of uh finding
the mode but because you have the log
there it makes everything easier right
and then you can show that you have the
same equations above if you make some
constraints in the type of
models right so um so what we did was
just like the obvious thing right to
transform that to generalize that to
some product networks with Goan leaves
and the idea is to use these induced
circuits so um an induced circuit just a
the composition of the of the
circuit
um such that you can write the
distribution as just this um mixture
model of these decompositions right so
for instance if you have that circuit
there on the left then you can decompose
in terms of these trees and you can add
the weights and the weights will be just
the product of all the weights that
appear in each um in each DEC
composition and then well the original
circuit is just this weighted mixture of
all these trees right you get something
like that uh which means that you can
have this view of protic circuits as
just like a gaan a mixture model right
if your leaves are Gauss then it's just
a gaan mixture models except that the
number of induced threes is exponential
in the size of the circuit it's just
like a gaan mixture models with
exponentially many
components um except also that these
components they actually um share some
of the parameters right so it is but it
isn't right um right so if we just plug
in that result here in the equations of
the mode o y um we can see like the only
thing I did was to replace the uh the
normal by this product of normals which
comes from one circuit and then the same
thing goes here so we got exactly the
same equations right instead of of
having the the density here I have the
density of some of the induced circuits
and I have this um this Factor here
which is kind of similar to what we uh
we had before which is just like the
what you get from the from the leaves
right from the gaans at the
leaves um right so of course this is not
really um efficient because you are
summing over an exponential number of
things but because you have this
structure of the the composability of
the circuit you can just actually do
efficiently in
the um in the circuit right so very
quickly let me just um tell you how the
aor works so um we actually have to
because we have actually to compute the
numerator part here and then we have to
compute this denominator right um so we
actually propagate like two um two
arrays so each node needs to compute the
numerator and the denominator and you
need to do that for each component of
the point that you are um you are
Computing right so this is like the next
point point and this is the J component
and for the J component you multiply by
the corresponding mean and for another
component you multiply by a different
number right so we actually kind of do
this all simultaneously in parallel
right I think it you might have be able
to do that with less space and doing two
passes instead of one but we haven't
actually tried all right so what diagram
does is that it is it it propagates
these two arrays so each array has a
value for every variable right um and
then we just propagate from bottom up we
compute these equations I don't think
they are that important uh but just to
show they are very similar to The
Standard computations except to
initialize with this weighted gaan in
the in the leaves and everything else is
just the same and then you just return
the ratio uh when you reach the root
right okay and then what we can show is
that if I give you a point and you run
this algorithm I get a point that is non
decreasing right so it might improve but
it might also converge to a sadow point
right which is just something we cannot
Escape because it's just the the proper
of em right uh in practice we see that
it's very difficult to converge to a
sadle point sadle points are very uh
unstable right so usually this is not
really a big problem and if you convert
to a SLE point it's usually quite easy
to check that it is Shadow point because
you can just like perturb the model and
you will probably escape the shadow
Point okay um and then why we are doing
this um so one thing that we did was
like um to to use that to have more uh
insight into the distribution right so
this is just like an illustrative
example where we use learn SPN to learn
circuit for the zero digits in the amist
and then we uh comp uh we try to find
all the modes that converges from the
data points in the training data right
and these are actually the the small
images here right um and that kind of
you know gives you um a view of your
distribution right so you know that
there is a region that is capturing all
these different types of of handwriting
and then what we did was just we
iterated we started with the modes
learned a new network right and
converted to the modes again then this
is the second line here right you can
think that of the kind of AG
agglomerative clustering right um it's
not so clear if this is actually useful
because uh if you do that too many times
of course you're just going to end up
with the kind of the mean of everything
right and you have some problems also
because um the these bags there have
different sizes so yeah but it gives you
some insight into the distribution I
think you can use it to to try to detect
some errors
right okay so just um to show another
illustrative example so we just run uh
this model
clustering um and then we are just
trying to compare um the difference
between doing clustering using the modes
and doing clustering em style you know
the typical way that people do right so
all these modes they have actually two
components but you can see that the ones
on the First Column which are doing
model clustering you actually have more
components right um so the idea is that
the modes they are not limited by the
number of components and all the other
methods they are somehow limited by the
number of components well not mean shift
because it's a per databased approach
but also seems to be somehow convergence
to the number of components
here whether this is good or bad then is
a I don't know
um so to have something that we can
actually have some more um understanding
if this is good or bad and we did the
same for image segmentation so I'm just
like a typical uh task in computer
vision so the idea is that you have you
want to kind of segment your image um
according to the color and locations of
the pixels so uh every pixel becomes a
data point and the you have like the X
and Y location and like the RGB colors
and this gives a data set we learn a
model and then from the model we
associate each PX each pixel to a color
right but we don't actually know how
many colors um we want right so what we
did was that we uh we build um um aan
mixture models right just product
network with the with the same um
structure of aan mixture model with six
components and we are just comparing to
K Mings here with six components just to
show that they are different right um
and then one thing that we can do is
like we can plot the locations of the
modes um and then we are just missing
the color of the modes but the color of
the modes are actually what you see in
the picture right um and and if you take
each point and then uh map into the mode
that it converges then you color this
image right and then you can see like uh
the first thing you see that you have
many more modes than
components um and you can capture some
uh nuance and stuff like uh you have the
beak of the duck here which is better
represented here than here right uh the
idea is that because when you fix the
number of components sometimes you have
to make
some force it to make some decisions and
you when you have the modes you're not
forc it to make those decisions right uh
on the other hand for instance you have
some artifacts so you have like a a mode
here which is probably just you know the
um some nuisance that comes from these
two modes which are closer to the
component means uh and actually you just
have like very few pixels Associated to
these modes right but I think it's
something that you can easily like
postprocessing and and and remove those
things right I think might be uh
useful um however we um you have very
specialized and very good aams in
computer vision for doing this right so
I'm not really defending this as a you
know competitive approach but it's a
kind of generic approach right you can
do that for whatever right you just need
a circuit it's not a very specialized
method right you can probably find um
similar
applications okay and then just to show
you if we increase the number of
components um H this is actually 30 not
20 um what what happens right so
curiously like when you go from six to
10 with 10 you actually just have 10
modes might might also just be because
of um the way we learn the networks but
if you go to 20 then you'll kind of find
this very weird uh Frontier here of
modes you know you have a lot of modes
here right um um and then with 30 then
also you actually decrease the number of
modes but you also get this weird
Frontier here of modes right so that
kind of show you something about
distribution right it looks like you are
learning a distribution that is uh for
some reason too complex over here right
it shouldn't be that complex you
shouldn't expect to have all these
models here
right
so what we wanted to do was like say can
we actually take this and try to improve
the distribution can we say you so like
somehow learn a simple a simpler model
here right we didn't have the time to do
that but so that was kind of the idea
right of this thing was more like to
refine the model than really use it for
for
this
okay um and then the last thing is that
we can uh do is to try to find our modes
right
um so this is a general strategy that
you can think of let's say well first we
need to kind of estimate how many modes
do we want to find and then we can try
to um estimate where we think the modes
might be and then we can just try to run
these algorithms that find a mode from
some start pointing from each one of
these regions right right so we have at
least two things here one is like to
determine the number of modes and the
other is to determine where where there
might be and of course this is kind of
related right if you know the second you
kind of know um the first one right uh
the difference is that once you have the
regions you can actually just count how
many modes you have found because
sometimes when you run these algorithms
you might actually end up in the same
mode right and if you if you knew that
you you expected to find more modes but
you are just conver to the same ones
then maybe you can like constrain your
search so that you don't end up in those
modes
right okay um so the question is can we
actually even know how many modes a gaan
mixture model has or a gaan some product
network has and this is kind of an open
question right so just to give you an
Insight so this is like one of the very
illustrative examples where you just
have two components two
gaan so it's a kind of small but these
arrows here they are the components and
you can see that the modes first the
modes there are not on the components
but you have some modes that are very
close to the components which is usually
the case and then you have one mode that
is very far from any component right
which is like in the interaction of the
components and actually this is the map
mode right if you want the most probable
mode it's the one that is farthest away
from all the possible components right
um so this greedy approach they probably
would fail to find these models right
you have somehow to know that you want
to start around this region to be able
to converge this guy right which for
this model is kind of uh simple you can
just consider the you know the
orthogonal lines but one thing you can
show is that you can scale this same
model to an arbitrary number of
distribution so you take any two
components any two
dimensions number of number of
Dimensions right you take any two uh
dimensions and you build something like
that right you have the degrees of
freedom and then you can show that the
number of modes that are far from the
components it grows exponentially in the
dimension right so you cannot really
just trial them all right okay and this
is um another um example which is I also
find kind of illustrative where again
you have the components
here and in this case they are uh
isotropic they all have the same
variance in every coordinate so every G
has the same variance and these are the
modes right and for this case there
every mode is a maximum one right but
you can probably kind of play with the
and make like this the maximum no or
whatever you want but then you probably
you need to not have isotropic gaan
right um so yeah this this just shows
that the the landscape of modes can be
quite complicated
right um so what people have been able
to show for G mixture models is is um if
the gaans are isotropic if all the gaans
have the same variance then you can show
that the modes are inside the convex
hole of the components means right so
this is already something because then
at least we can we know where to look
for the modes we can start the
components and then kind of refine and
look inside and so
on but if you have know is Tropic GA
which I believe like is what we want in
practice then the molds can lie outside
the convex hole which was just the first
example and we don't even know if like
if you draw a hyper rectangle according
around the the mode components if it the
modes are there right so we really don't
know where the modes are here they could
be anywhere right so we have no idea
actually how to even look for the modes
of course we can find some modes but we
don't know if they're um the ones we
want uh what most of the times we do
actually sometimes we do have data we
learn our models from data and then the
data is actually a good starting
pointing for for to look for the modes
right so this is actually we end up
doing in practice and I suspect I though
I haven't proved that if you just go
deeper in the circuit you just get more
and more complex uh things right so this
will just make everything more
complicated yes why outside the con
Max yeah so we don't know that yeah so I
suspect this is true but not even that
we know if it's really true
yeah um right and then the other thing
was okay can we at least know how many
modes even if you don't know where they
are because at least we can't see right
if you f but yeah so we also don't know
about that so what people have shown is
that like
um if you have any dimensional gaan
mixture models with only two components
you can already have as many as any plus
one
modes um but if you have more than two
components then you can already have
exponentially many modes in the
dimensions right um the only upper bound
that we have is this thing here so like
to the power of the number of of the
dimensions of the variables and then
quadratic on the number of not Lo and
times this bound here so this is
probably really really loose right um so
for instance if you plug in K 100 and uh
n50 which is just some something that
would be not even a very large
probabilistic circuit that's already
give you 10 to the^ of 29 possible modes
so yeah we don't expect to have that
many U modes right right didn't you say
in the beginning that we might have
infinitely want yes uh but that's not
for Gauss
right okay so just to conclude so this
is my defense here that I think that
finding modes is an interesting way to
look at your distribution when it's
quite complicated I think it has some
useful applications I think is a quite
challenging problem um I think we've uh
most people have been looking at the
discrete case is interesting because in
the continuous case in the gaan in
particular there are a lot of things
that you can do right um that you
doesn't make much sense in the discrete
case and there is also much less work
done for the continuous case right
someone wants to um looking for a
problem I think this might be a good
idea um there is also a lot of open
questions about the modes itself right
the landscape of mode how many uh where
they are are if can you I'm just talking
about location and the numbers but
usually we might be more interested in
say the modes there are in probable
regions right in high density regions
and stuff like that right and I think
probably we can show something about
that right people haven't showed
that okay that's all thank
[Applause]
you
this uh this mode shifting algorithm is
this uh is this actually connected to um
cadient ascent and like maybe like that
you pre multiply with some funky um
positive definite Matrix is is
essentially like a yeah so is there a
connection yeah it's variational
inference right I think you can look at
it that way but you don't derive it from
that right it's doing gradient Ascent in
some way right but you don't have a
learning rate or anything like that and
it's not exactly like a second ordered
method em right it's just
em on the data right on the data yeah
all right thanks again okay thank
you
guess we'll reconvene at uh 11:25 for uh
circuits for language
models